All right.
Woohoo!
Tonight's lecture is titled the battle
of the giants and we are going back into
the bible tonight. This is a expose of
Revelation chapter 12. The book of
Revelation by John.
Revelation is God's protection from last
day delusions. So as we have seen,
Revelation tells us exactly who the main
role players are going to be at the end
of time, who's going to be involved in
bringing about these great delusions and
deceptions, and how we can avoid them.
It describes an enormous struggle
between the forces of good and the
forces of evil. And it's just a brief
summary. The details of the war are
given in the chapters prior to chapter
12 and in the chapters post chapter 12.
So tonight we're just going to look at
the struggle and we're going to pick up
on one or two important little
components and then we're going to go in
the next lectures to the hub of the
matter and see who's who and who is
described.
Well, the battle started
not only in Eden before that even, but
Genesis 1:27. So God created man in his
own image, in the image of God.
He created him male and female. He
created them. This is a fantastic new
creation where God creates being that
are male and female. And God said, "Let
us make man in our image." There's a
plural over there after our likeness.
And let them have dominion over the fish
of the sea, the fowl of the air, the
cattle, the over all the earth, and
every creeping thing that creepeth upon
the earth. This is a brand new scenario.
Brand new. Because here God is creating
an order of being that is to have
dominion. None of the angels had
dominion.
None of the angels had been created male
and female. This was a new order. The
Bible tells us clearly that angels are
not like we are.
And why would God do this? You see, God
was creating a new order of being who
would understand the mindset of God even
in the capacity of his creative ability.
Because by bringing forth life and
nurturing that life, we can learn to
understand what it means to have the
watch care of a loving God. If we bring
forth children into this world, we know
that we have to plant a hedge of
protection around them. Love requires
it. Doesn't that make sense? Love
requires it. And so God had put a hedge
of protection around his creation which
is known as the commandments of God. But
God was misunderstood at the level of
his creation because they believed that
they were now subject to rules even
though they were themselves exalted
beings. And so this battle arose. God's
answer in part to this problem is a new
order of being. God blessed them and God
said unto them, "Be fruitful and
multiply." He hadn't said that to any
other angel. "Replenish the earth,
subdue it, have dominion." He hadn't
said that to an angel either. God is the
only one who had dominion. Over the fish
of the sea, and over the fowl of the
air, and over every living thing that
moves upon the earth. Genesis 1:26-28.
And out of the ground
made the Lord God to grow every tree
that is pleasant to the sight and good
for food, and the tree of life also in
the midst of the garden, and the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil. So God
gave them a choice. God said, "Here's a
choice. You can choose to know the good
and to practice the good or you can
choose the knowledge of evil and have
sadness, pain and death. Choice is
yours. Free agents. You can choose. The
greatest gift that God has ever given
to anything in the universe is the gift
of choice. Because without the gift of
choice, we would be robots. And any love
that we receive from anyone else would
be by force or compulsion or programming
but wouldn't be by choice making it
meaningless. But the very nature of
choice requires that we can actually
choose. That means we can choose against
God. And that is a risk that God took.
But he didn't take it lightly. He was
prepared to die for it.
Now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which Jehovah God had
made. And he said unto the woman, "Yay,
has God said, you shall not eat of any
tree of the garden?" So he questions the
word of God. Well, he still does that
today. He's very good at that. It's
called higher criticism.
We may eat of the tr fruit from the
trees of the garden, but God did say you
must not eat fruit from the tree that is
in the middle of the garden and you must
not touch it or you will die. Genesis 3
2 and 3. So in other words, death would
be the consequence because simply put,
if you take it right down to its final
analysis, if you choose not to follow
the requirements of God, you will have
suffering, mayhem, death, murder,
illness, disease, all those things
brought upon you because you separate
yourself willfully from God. Well, that
is your choice then.
Well, Adam and Eve chose
and they chose not to follow the
requirements of God. Genesis 3:24 says,
"So he drove out the man and he placed
at the east of the garden of Eden the
cherubam and the flame of the sword
which turned every way to keep the way
of the tree of life."
So man was cut off from the tree of
life. Did he instantly die?
No. He had so much vitality at that
stage that it took him a while to
actually die. So the death that we're
talking about is not just the physical
death. We're talking about total death.
The wages of sin is death. Romans 6:23.
Not a transition from one phase to
another. It's death. It's what the Bible
says. And all the days that Adam lived
were 930 years and then he died. Genesis
5:5. He was dead.
Well, did God leave man to this death?
No. He had a promise for him, a
solution. Genesis 3:15, "And I will put
enmity between thee
and the woman,
and between thy seed and her seed,
he shall bruise thy head, and thou shalt
bruise his heel." Now, was Eve in
trouble from that day onwards?
Well, Eve died sometime after that. And
who is then in trouble now?
Surely that is not a reference to Eve.
So who is the woman? Well, we'll come to
that in some more detail. A woman in the
Bible used in this prophetic sense is a
symbol of God's people. And we'll
discuss this in a moment. So when the
Bible speaks of a woman, a bride, then
it is a symbol of those that are
betrothed
to God. That's his people. So in other
words, I will put enmity between
God's people and between thy seed, that
is Lucifer's people, Satan's people, and
her seed, singular.
Out of her would come the seed that
would save mankind. And that seed says
Paul is singular reference to Jesus and
anybody who is in Jesus can have eternal
life through him.
He masculine
the seed the savior shall bruise thy
head and thou shalt bruise his heel. So
there will be a war between them. Now
the Roman Catholic Church not liking it
the way it is using the symbol of the
woman as the church changes it to mean
Mary who was not alive at that time and
wasn't going to be alive for a long long
time meaning that well the serpent would
have had free reign for quite a few
thousand re years which makes no sense
whatsoever so that UA rhymes online
Bible says I will put enmity between
thee and the woman and thy seed and her
seed and she shall crush thy head and
thou shalt lie and wait for her heal.
That's turned the whole gospel upside
down that has made somebody else the
savior. So right from the beginning it
seems there was this conflict. So in
Revelation 12, we pick up the story. And
there appeared a great wonder in heaven,
a woman clothed with the sun.
Interesting. A great wonder, a woman
clothed with the sun. And the moon under
her feet. We have two symbols there, the
moon and the sun. And upon her head a
crown of 12 stars. So the number 12 is
significant.
And she being with child cried
travailing in birth and pain to be
delivered. Now Catholicism makes that
literal and says Mary is going to have a
child.
But if you take it prophetically that
means out of God's people the Messiah
will come. That's what it means. And
there appeared another one day in
heaven. And behold a great red dragon
having seven heads and 10 horns and
seven crowns upon his heads. And we've
spoken about all of those issues before.
The dragon, as we will find out, is
Satan or Lucifer, the fallen angel, the
seven heads, a reference to what we saw
in the book of Daniel where all the
kingdoms of the world have seven heads
if you tie them up. So over the course
of history, what the battle would be and
10 horns and seven crowns upon his head.
So Lucifer is the ultimate ruler behind
the scenes. The 10 horns is a reference
to the kingdoms.
Well, here is this Roman Catholic web
page that we've read before. Just to
bring it to into perspective here. It is
no surprise that the woman would triumph
over the red dragon, for scripture says
so at the very beginning. Refer Genesis
3:15, which states, "And I will
establish a feud between thee and the
woman, between thy offspring and hers.
She is to crush thy head, while thou
dost lie in ambush at her heels." So
which version are they quoting?
They're quoting the Roman Catholic
version, right? They're quoting the
Jesuit Bible version. Not even their own
good news quotes it like that. Even the
Good News Bible has it right. Only the
Jesuit one quotes it wrong. Strange that
they should use it or not strange,
understandable that they should use this
to substantiate their theology. They
continue to say to Mary, the woman of
scripture and mother of the men, notice
this, who keep the commandments and hold
fast to the truths concerning Jesus.
Well, that is a distortion of the text
as well because it doesn't read like
that. But this is a quote, a distorted
quote from Revelation 12:1 17. Very
interesting. So, they apply Revelation
12:1 17 to those who honor Mary and keep
her commandments. Is that basically what
she's saying?
>> Good.
The church applies the beautiful words
of wisdom. She the glow that radiates
from eternal love. She the unarnished
mirror of God's majesty. She the
faithful image of his goodness. Now who
is really the express image of his
brightness?
Jesus. So here we have a conflict. We
have a conflict between two ideologies
because Mary is full of grace. Luke
1:28, the church through Pope Pas the
9th in his infibilis deos and apostolic
constitution issued on December 8, 1854
confirmed the tradition, note the word
tradition, they know it's not biblical,
that held Mary as being conceived
immaculate.
So the Roman Catholic Church applies
Revelation 12
to Mary.
Of
course, the reference is also that we
keep her commandments because that is
the battle. Well, the pope can modify
divine law. Prompta biblote papa article
two.
And if we look at the ten commandments
as they are given in the Bible
and we compare it with the ten
commandments as given by the Roman
Catholic Church, even their Bible, their
official Bible has it right. Only their
catechism book has it wrong.
The original commandments given by God,
thou shalt have no other gods before me.
Well, I am the Lord your God. You shall
have no other gods before me. That's the
same. The second commandment, thou shalt
not make for thyself any graven image or
any likeness or anything in heaven above
on the earth beneath shall not bow down
to them etc etc etc. That commandment is
gone here gone in the Roman Catholic
catechism.
So the third commandment
thou shalt not take the name of the Lord
thy God in vain. Now here becomes the
second commandment. You see that?
Remember the Sabbath day. Keep holy the
Sabbath day is now the third commandment
which was the fourth. And then the rest
are the same. Honor thy father, thy
mother, do not steal, etc. Do not kill,
etc. all the way down. Thou shalt not
bear false witness. Thou shalt not bear
false witness. But they've taken out
one. So now they have to divide the 10th
into two which is the thou shalt not
coveret commandment which Paul clearly
lists as one commandment. Thou shalt not
coveret thy neighbor's house. Thou shalt
not coveret thy neighbor's wife, nor his
man's servant, nor his maid servant, nor
his ox, nor his ass, nor anything that
is thy neighbors. Now, please note how
they have to turn it around because it
really doesn't make a any sense to say
as a whole commandment, thou shalt not
coveret thy neighbor's house. That
doesn't make any sense, right? So,
they've split it rather the other way
around and made the ninth commandment.
Thou shalt not coveret thy neighbor's
wife. Well, at least they acknowledge
that the wife is more important than the
house.
and then thou shalt not coveret thy
neighbor's goods. So they've split that
round a little bit. Now Protestantism
in the Axbour confession is just a
little bit more honest than that and
leaves it in the right order although
the commandments don't make much sense
then. So that's an interesting analogy.
So one commandment is gone and uh one
commandment the day has been shifted.
The Sabbath now here is not the seventh
day but the first day and the 10th
commandment is split into two so that we
have ten commandments again. So this is
the law of Catholicism
and those that follow Mary must keep
these commandments as we will see in
another lecture which is quite an
interesting little tugofwar between two
rulers. The God of heaven and the prince
of this world.
Well, we continue. The Catholic
Encyclopedia admits it quite freely. The
church after changing the day of rest
from the Jewish Sabbath or the seventh
day of the week to the first made the
third commandment which although it
should be the fourth commandment so here
they admit that they must have removed
one otherwise it wouldn't be the third
one right they admit it refer to Sunday
as the day to be kept holy as the Lord's
day
but Jesus says in Matthew chapter 5:17
think not that I am come to destroy the
law and the prophets, I'm not come to
destroy, but to fulfill, to live them
out, to show you. And then he continues
to say, not one jot or one tit will by
any means disappear from the law until
all has been accomplished till heaven
and earth pass away. Not one jot, not
one tit will pass from the law. So
according to the Bible, the law stands
forever. Roman Catholicism says, "No, we
are above the Bible. We change the law."
Revelation 12:4
and his tail, this is now the serpent's
tail, drew the third part of the stars
of heaven. And if you look at Hebrew
parallelism in the Bible, you'll find
that the stars represent in this
prophetic sense angels. So we can say
that Satan drew onethird of the angels
with him and it casts them to the earth.
And the dragon stood before the woman
which was ready to be delivered for to
devour her child as soon as it was born.
Out of God's people would come the
Messiah. And Satan was watching the
times of fulfillment which are given in
the book of Daniel precisely.
And he was looking and waiting for the
deliverance of this child. And when this
child was to be born, he wanted to
destroy him instantly.
and she brought forth a manchild who was
to rule all nations with a rod of iron.
And a child was caught up unto God and
to his throne. In one verse, you have
the birth of the Messiah and you have
his
resurrection and you have his ascension
into heaven all in one verse. But you
can see it's a very masculine verse
although Catholicism would like to
emulate it. And therefore they have
Mary's ascension into heaven. So she
also dies but is woken up and has an
ascension into heaven. So everything is
a counterfeit.
And the woman fled into the wilderness
where she has a place prepared of God
that she should feed her there a,23
score days. Now if this is Mary, we have
a problem, right?
If this is Mary, we have a problem
because how does Mary fulfill the
prophecy of fleeing into a wilderness
for 1,260
days? Prophetically speaking,
if we continue, and there was war in
heaven. So, it's a backtrack. God is
explaining what happened, why there is
this battle on this earth. And it says
there was war in heaven.
Michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon fought and his
angels. So there was a war in heaven
already.
Revelation verse 8 12:8 says and
prevailed not. So the dragon did not
prevail, neither was their place found
anymore in heaven. So a third of the
angels rebelled against the government
of God. There must have been a battle
for the minds of the angels. And I can
imagine that Satan worked with all
cunning deception that you can imagine,
insinuating hate, insinuating
unfairness,
and insinuating that he was deeply
wronged as the main angel in heaven not
to receive more honor and glory. Sad,
sad story. He does the same today.
Everybody has a hunger for glory and
that can only be satisfied if others are
obsuous and bowed down to you. That is
when you get your glory satisfied on
this earth. And that's probably what he
tried in heaven. And Jesus
being the humble one that he is never
used his methodology. He never forced
himself upon anyone, but just let his
character speak for itself. And so it
came to a rebellion,
but he prevailed not. Neither was their
place found anymore in heaven. Now,
Michael and his angels. Now, who's
Michael? The Jehovah's Witnesses will
tell us Michael is a archangel, an
archangel.
But what does Michael mean? Mael, look
it up in any children's book for names.
What does Mael mean? It means he that is
what God is. H
he that is what God is. When God came to
this earth as man, he was to be called
Emmanuel,
God with us. Call his name Yesua.
Yave the savior. You see the name has a
meaning. You know we today have a name
and that's it. But in biblical times the
name had a meaning, a very special
meaning. And so you find that names
change as circumstances change in the
Bible. Can you think of any such
interesting cases when names change?
When circumstances change? Didn't Jacob
become
Israel?
Israel. Now, Jacob means the suppler,
the one who takes the place of. And he
was the second to come out, but he took
the place of the first by tricking him
of which he repented later. Most
certainly repented.
But when he had found Christ, when he
had wrestled with God for forgiveness,
repented of his sin,
then he was called Israel.
He who had wrestled with God and
overcome. See, name changed because
circumstances had changed. Now, Mikail,
he who is what God is. Let's have a
look. Who is Mikail?
MK is called in Daniel 10 21 your ruler.
So he's the ruler of God's people. Well,
who's the ruler of God's people?
Jesus.
But Jesus was in heaven before he came
down to earth. Is that correct? Yes or
no? Yeah. He was in heaven before he
came down to earth. And he was not Yesua
Yave, the Savior that had come to die
for us. No, he was MK. He who is what
God is. Let's continue. And at that time
shall Michael stand up, the great prince
which stands for the children of thy
people. Daniel 12:1. Who's the great
prince that stands for us? There's only
one. The Bible makes it quite clear.
Jesus is the one who stands for us. But
Michael the Archangel when contending
with the devil, he argued about the body
of Moses. Jude 9. Who has the right to
argue over the body of someone that is
to be resurrected?
Who? Only God. Only Jesus has the right
to do that. Did he raise Moses from the
dead? Yes or no? Absolutely. How do we
know? Because Moses appeared to him on
the mount of transfiguration.
And how do we know that? Well, here he
was resurrected.
And who else appeared with him? Elijah
and Elijah never saw death. So one
represents those who will be translated
without seeing death, Elijah. And one
represents those who will be resurrected
through the power of the same Christ and
have eternal life. Well, let's see if
the Bible applies this word archangel.
For the Lord himself, now we know that
it's Jesus Christ, shall descend from
heaven with a shout, with a voice of the
archangel,
and with a trumpet of God, and the dead
in Christ shall rise first. John 5:28
says that it is the voice of the son of
man.
All right? So, this voice of the
archangel is the voice of the son of
man. Then who is he then?
Then he's God. You see the word
archangel can mean an angel, highest
angel but it also means the highest
messenger.
Now what is the greatest message of the
godhood?
The manifestation of the godhood that
can touch us and reach us and talk to us
and communicate and make us accessible
to God. So the greatest message that God
has is himself in the form of he who is
what God is. Miko. All right. So now we
see that the Bible uses this word
archangel for the voice of the son of
man. Let's see if we can find this angel
in the Old Testament. Genesis 48:16.
The angel who redeemed me from all evil.
Now we have a problem. If we're going to
make an angel a created being, right?
Who's the only one who can redeem you?
Jesus. So this redeeming angel over here
is Jesus. Go further. And the angel of
the Lord appeared to him in a flame of
fire. Exodus 3:2.
Now, who's that? Well, it must be the
same one. By the way, if this was a
created being, why did he command
worship? Didn't he say, "You are on holy
ground. Take off your shoes." And he
worshiped him. Yes or no? Yes. So,
here's an angel that receives worship.
So this can only be God. This is not a
created angel. This is one who going
forth has been from forever. In all
their afflictions he was afflicted and
the angel of his presence. Now there you
have the nice nutshell
saved them in his love and in his pity
he redeemed them. Isaiah 63:9.
So, Michael and his angels is Jesus
Christ and the heavenly host.
And then you have the dragon and his
angels.
So, who is the dragon?
The great dragon was cast out, that old
serpent called devil, Satan who deceives
the whole world. Revelation 12:9. Pretty
plain and simple. There we go. Where did
the devil come from? Ezekiel 28:13. Thou
hast been in Eden in the garden of God.
Every precious stone was thy covering in
the day that thou was created. He's a
created being whether he likes it or
not. He is a created being. Thou art the
anointed cherub that coverereth. So
Satan when he was Lucifer was one of the
covering cherubs that stood over the ark
of the covenant.
Thou was perfect in the way in thy ways
from the day that thou was created till
iniquity was found in thee. A mystery.
Why should iniquity come into Lucifer
when he was perfect from the day that he
was created? Why should it happen?
Obviously, he was created with what?
Freedom of choice.
So he's a order of being
in the image of God because he has
freedom of choice and he at some stage
chose to let jealousy and selfishness
rule his hearts
and thou has sinned. What is sin?
Transgressing God's law. That's what one
John says. In fact, that's the only
definition given in the Bible for what
it is. Therefore, I will cast thee as
profane out of the mountain of God, and
I will destroy thee, oh covering cherub,
from the midst of the stones of fire.
Thine heart was lifted up because of thy
beauty.
Here we have
pride that has corrupted thy wisdom
because of thy brightness, that has
defiled thy sanctuaries by the multitude
of thine iniquities. So he started off
his own church if you like. Therefore
will I bring forth a fire from the midst
of thee. It shall devour thee and I will
bring thee to ashes upon the earth in
the sight of all them that behold him
and never shalt thou be anymore. What
will happen with Satan at the end? He
will be destroyed. That's not what the
Christian world teaches there. But this
is what the Bible says. We'll have to
look at that in some detail as well.
So what is masonry? highmasonry now and
the secret doctrine of masonry do with
this concept they have to turn it upside
down. Do you remember these quotes? Let
me give them to you. The Appalachian
Satan in Hebrew Satan and adversary from
the word satana to be adverse to
persecute belongs by right to the first
and crulest adversary of all the other
gods Jehovah.
Wow. not to the serpent which spoke only
words of sympathy and wisdom and is at
the worst even in the dogma the
adversary of men. Okay. Secret doctrines
volume 2 page 388. Now I have those
books. So this is genuine. It stands
there. It's not hearsay. So what has the
inner circle of Jesuit teaching done to
the doctrine of God being the one who
cares and loves us and saves us? What
has it done to that doctrine? Turned it
upside down. You see, they say God
wanted to prevent us from knowing
something. Yes, God wanted to prevent us
from knowing something. He wanted to
prevent us from knowing evil
because he never wanted a mother to cry
at the grave of her dead son or
daughter. That's why. And he never
wanted the heartache that we have on
this planet. Yes, would be a good thing
if we never knew evil. Would be a very
good thing, but unfortunately we're
living with it. So they turn it upside
down. Now the good guy is the serpent
and the bad guy is Yave.
Secret Doctrine Volume 2 page 319.
Therefore Jehovah was called by the
Gnostics the creator of and one of the
offomorphs
the serpent Satan or evil. All right. So
we've turned it upside down in masonry
and in the inner circle of the Roman
Catholic Church. Remember that it was
formed and created by the Jesuit order
and we have a whole lecture on that. The
secret behind secret societies. You
remember that one? Secret doctrine page
418. Eoteric explanation. May I ever
bring some order in this confusion?
Because the Bible now says the exact
oppos opposite. Let's look at it from
the esoteric point of view says Blavzki
in which Jehovah becomes Saturn
and Michael and his army. Isn't that
interesting? So they also believe that
Jehovah is Michael.
Satan and the rebellious angels owing to
the indiscrete endeavors of the two
faithful zealots to see in every pagan
god a devil. H okay interesting. Let's
make it even clearer. Secret doctrine
volume 2 page 508. that Michael being
simply Jehovah himself,
one of the subordinate spirits at best.
Okay, so if we're looking at the story,
then we see Mael, the one who is what
God is and his angels fighting against
the dragon who has been cast down to the
s the serpent.
They turn it around and say, "No, the
bad guy is
Jehovah." But they are free to admit
still, this is the strange thing, that
it is the good guy who's down on earth
here now. So they're admitting at least
that he got licked up there and got
thrown out.
Well, let's see. Secret doctrine, volume
1, page 71. The devil is now called
darkness by the church, whereas in the
Bible, he's called the son of God, the
bright star of the early morning.
Lucifer. There's a whole philosophy of
dogmatic craft in the reason why the
first archangel who sprang from the
depth of chaos was called looks Lucifer
the luminous son of the morning a man
vantaric dawn. He was transformed by the
church into Lucifer or Satan because he
is brighter and older than Jehovah and
had to be sacrificed to the new dogma
who
biting.
Revelation 12:7-9.
And the great dragon was cast out, that
old serpent called the devil and Satan,
which deceives the whole world. He was
cast out into the earth, and his angels
were cast out with him. That's what the
Bible says. You can choose whether you
want to believe the one or the other.
Bible says he got thrown out. Even the
inner circle of masonry believed that
the one ruling down here now got thrown
out. But they say he will be reinstated.
That's not what the Bible says.
Revelation 12:10 and 11. And I heard a
loud voice saying in heaven, now is come
salvation and strength, and the kingdom
of our God, and the power of his Christ,
for the accuser of our brethren is cast
down, which accused them before our God
day and night. So the Bible says devil
is down here, not the good guy.
and they overcame him by the blood of
the lamb and by the word of their
testimony and they loved not their lives
unto death. So here Jesus came to this
earth. He died for us. He demonstrated
to us that God is love. There is no
greater evidence than this. God is love.
And you can believe their lie or you can
believe this.
Revelation 12:12, "Therefore rejoice ye
heavens and ye that dwell in them."
That's the angelic host. Because they
must have had a long time of misery,
too. This war has been going on for a
long time. Woe to the inhabitants of the
earth and of the sea. That's the
peoples, the nations. For the devil is
come down and to you having great wroth
because he knows that he has but a short
time. So God is going to limit his time.
God is going to cut his little
experiment with sin short.
So when we look at these beginning
verses in Revelation 12, there appeared
a great wonder in heaven, a woman
clothed with the sun,
that is the church of God
with the power of Jesus Christ behind
her and the moon under her feet. That is
the law and the equipment to fight it.
The lesser light, we reflecting the
greater light. And upon her head a crown
of 12 stars. There were 12 tribes of
Israel. There were 12 apostles in the
early church. She being with child cried
prevailing in birth and pain to be
delivered.
Now let's go and look at this woman in a
little bit more detail. Malachi 4:2.
But unto you that fear my name shall the
son of righteousness arise with healing
in his wings. So Jesus is called the son
s u n of righteousness. Now Lucifer
takes the symbol of the son which is
applied to Jesus Christ and applies it
to himself. He takes all the credit. He
turns the whole gospel upside down. His
seed shall endure forever and his throne
as the son before me. Psalms 89:36.
So the sun is used as a symbol of Jesus.
And Satan takes the symbol and applies
it to his worship in the end.
Psalms 89:37, it shall be established
forever as the moon and as a faithful
witness in heaven. A witness of what?
it. What does the moon do in in order
for us to see it?
It reflects the light of the sun. So the
faithful witness, the moon under her
feet is reflecting the glory of Jesus
Christ to the world. That's his people.
Only his people can do that because
Jesus doesn't have to reflect his glory.
He is his own glory. So this is God's
people. 1 Peter 2:9, "But you are a
chosen generation, a royal priesthood, a
holy nation, a peculiar people." This is
what we are supposed to be. Jeremiah 6:2
makes it a little bit more clear. I have
likened the daughter of Zion to a comely
and delicate woman. So, here's the
comparison. God's people
is a are likened compared to a beautiful
woman Zion. Who are they? Let's just
make quite sure. Isaiah 51:16 say unto
Zion, "Thou art my people." So we have
the parallelism.
God's people have been compared to a
cumbly and delicate woman. Isaiah 54:5,
"For thy maker is thine husband, the
Lord of hosts is his name, and thy
redeemer, the Holy One of Israel, the
God of the whole earth, shall he be
called. For the Lord has called thee as
a
woman forsaken and grieved in spirit,
and a wife of youth when thou was
refused, says thy God." So, is this Mary
or is this God's people? It's definitely
God's people.
Hosea 2:19, "And I will betro thee unto
me forever. Yeah, I will betro thee unto
me in righteousness, and in judgments,
and in loving kindness, and in mercies.
I will even betro thee unto me in
faithfulness, and thou shalt know the
Lord. For I am jealous over you with
godly jealousy, not human jealousy. For
I have espoused you to one husband, that
I may present you as a chasted virgin to
Christ." 2 Corinthians 11:2.
The symbology there is the symbolism is
amazing. The woman is the church and she
being with child cried travailing in
birth and pain to be delivered.
Revelation 12:2 and she brought forth a
manchild who was to rule all nations
with a rod of iron and a child was
caught up unto God and to his throne. So
out of God's people would come
uh the Messiah. John 4:22, "You worship,
ye know not what Jesus says to the woman
at the well, we know as speaking as a
Jew, what we worship, for salvation
is of the Jews, God's people." So out of
God's people would come the Messiah.
Psalms 2:7-9, I will declare the decree,
"The Lord has said unto me, thou art my
son. In this day I have begotten thee.
Ask me, and I shall give the heathen for
thine inheritance, and the uttermost
parts of the earth for thy possession.
Thou shalt break them with a rod of
iron. Thou shalt dash them in pieces
like a potter's vessel. God will be the
victor in this tremendous battle.
Revelation 19:15 says, "And out of his
mouth goes a sharp sword that with it he
should smite the nations, and he shall
rule them with a rod of iron, and he
treadth the wine press of the fierceness
of the wroth of Almighty God." God's
wroth is not our wroth. It is poured out
without anger. It is poured out with
tears.
>> Revelation 12:3.
And there appeared another wonder in
heaven, and behold, a great red dragon
having seven heads and 10 horns and
seven crowns upon his heads, and his
tail drew a third part of the stars out
of heaven. Satan is down here now.
stands before the woman which was ready
to be delivered for to devour the child
as soon as it was born. And when Jesus
was born, he was ready. And he waited to
have this child destroyed. And he sent
out the Roman legions to go and kill
every little boy that was in Bethlehem
and surrounds. And the little skulls
were everywhere. And today even in some
monasteries you can find these skulls
and they say these are the children that
Herod killed and they mercilessly
slaughtered. But God took his son and
they fled to Egypt. But eventually he
did kill him and crucify him for the
wages of sin is death. But the gift of
God is eternal life through Jesus Christ
our Lord. Romans 6:23.
And then he ascended into heaven where
he sits on the right hand of the father
and he will come to reclaim his kingdom.
And I pray that we may all be on his
side. Now the adversary side. Let's have
a look at this. Hebrews 2:14.
Since the children have flesh and blood,
he too shared in their humanity so that
by his death he might destroy him who
holds the power of death. that is the
devil.
So the devil thought he had him beat. He
thought he had him licked. And the
greatest apparent defeat turned into the
greatest victory of all time. So the Old
Testament church was guided and
protected by God so that it could
proclaim and bring forth the Messiah.
Revelation 12:13. And the dragon
persecuted the woman which brought forth
the manchild. Now is this Mary
or what did the dragon do after the Lord
had been taken up to heaven? What did he
do? He persecuted God's people. So the
dragon, Satan, now goes for those who
profess Jesus Christ. Revelation 12:6.
And the woman fled into the wilderness.
That's a place
of porcity of people, not many nations.
A wilderness, dry place hidden to the
solitary places
where she has a place prepared of God
that they should feed her there a,23
score days. Revelation 12:6. Now, we've
heard that one before. Now, let's look
at some Hebrew parallelism here. 1,260
days. If we go to Revelation 12:14, we
have the same symbolism. And to the
woman, there's the woman. We're given
two wings of a great eagle that she
might fly into the wilderness into her
place where she is nourished for a time,
times, and half a time from the face of
the serpent. So, we have two times
mentioned here. 1,260 days time times in
half a time, but we have the same
symbolism. We have the woman, we have
the wilderness, and we have a time. What
does that tell us? That it's the same
time period. Prophetically, it's the
same time period. I have appointed thee
at each day for a year. Ezekiel 4:6. So,
that would mean 1,200
prophetic days, making it 1,260
literal years.
And we have these time periods in Daniel
7:25, time, times, and the dividing of
times. Daniel 12:7, time, times, and
half a time. 3 and a half prophetic
years, 3 and 1 half times 360, 1,260.
42 months, 42 prophetic months, 30 days
per month. That was the Hebrew month. 30
* 42, 1,260,
1260, 1260. Times and half a time, 40
and two months. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Seven
times. Seven is the number of
completeness. This power takes the place
of God gets it seven times. Now, we've
dealt with this before the 1,260day
period when we dealt with Revelation 11.
So, I'm not going to deal with this in
detail. Suffice to say that the papal
system officially commenced its rule in
538 and was officially ended in 1798 in
an apparent wound when Berta took the
pope captive and Napoleon declared that
the rule of the papacy was at an end. Of
course, the Bible says the wound will
heal and she will once again qualify as
a beast and the whole world will follow
her. But during this 1,260day
period from 538 to 1798, the papacy
relentlessly persecuted God's people who
scattered and hid themselves in the
wilderness. Numbers 151-53,
the tabernacle was pitched in the midst
of the people. And John 1:14, Jesus in
the midst of his people, the tabernacle,
the way to salvation, Jesus the door,
Jesus the sacrifice. Jesus the one who
washes you. Jesus the light of the
world, the intercessor, the bread of
life, the one who shields us from the
consequences of the law. That's the
story of the tabernacle and covers us
with his righteousness. That all stands
for Jesus Christ, the church in the
wilderness and the tabernacle in the
wilderness. Beautiful parallels between
the Old and the New Testament. So,
Satan's object was to attack God's
church. He was furious. He had not
overcome Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ had
been raised from the dead. He knew his
battle was lost and now he was raging.
Who was going to be his
sword? Revelation 17:3, I saw a woman
sit upon a scarlet colored beast full of
names of blasphemy. We've dealt with
that in detail. Upon her forehead was a
name written, mystery Babylon the Great,
the mother of harlots and abominations
of the earth. Revelation 17:5. We dealt
with that in detail. The mystery Babylon
the great. The city of Babylon had its
origin when God confused the languages
at the Tower of Babel. The term Babylon
in Revelation represents religious
confusion and Babel,
another portal to God, another way of
being saved. So what does the system
represent?
Number one, it represents the authority
of man.
Number two, the word of man. They
changed the word of God. They're the
ones that going to give the norms. The
works of man, how to be saved by your
deeds. The law of man, how they changed
it eventually into human rights, and the
traditions of man.
Well, God says we must choose. 1 Kings
18:21. And Elijah came unto all the
people and said, "How long halt ye
between two opinions? If the Lord be
God, follow him. But if Baal then follow
him. Is there a choice here?
Yes, we still have freedom of choice.
Thank God. So this tendency to meet
paganism halfway was very early
developed. Upright men strove to stem
the tide. But the apostasy went on till
the church with the exception of a small
remnant was submerged under pagan
superstition. The two Babylons by hisop
page 93.
And so paganism came into the church
masquerading as Christianity. We have
had a look at the symbolism the half
moon or the sickle moon and the star
symbolizing the birth of the Messiah
that would empower you to become gods
and live forever.
And it had the same system in
Mesopotamia as they had in Egypt where
they had the trinity Isis Horus set. The
Gnostics turned the whole gospel upside
down made us God and Jesus Christ the
devil.
The son became the source of physical
life. The serpent the source of
spiritual life. And Esclius became the
lifegiving serpents. and uh the serpent
god and in all spheres he was the great
healer. So in medicine pharmacea
pharmacy pharmmacea means witchcraft
it's the same word word for witchcraft
is pharmacea
the same over here he will be the healer
so we have a mystery of iniquity 2
Thessalonians 270 2:7 and a mystery
Babylon the great revelation 17:5
so another system of salvation to
Timothy 4:4 they will turn away from
listening to the truth and give their
attention to legends. How do you make
war against the woman? Physically and
spiritually
and the times of his ignorance God
winked at. I like this text Acts 17
verse 30 because the question is always
asked, what about the poor people who do
not know? What about the poor people in
Catholicism today who worship God
according to the best dictates of their
conscience? What about them? Are they
all going to be lost? No.
In the times of this ignorance, God wked
at their ignorance. He closed an eye. He
judges them according to the light that
they have and according to their ability
to do what is right given the
circumstances of their knowledge. That's
a fair God. I like that.
Therefore, to him that knoweth to do
good and doeth it not, to him it is sin.
James 4:17. Oops, there's the flip side.
In other words, if you know what right
and wrong is and you do it not, what
then?
than it is for your sin. Then you become
responsible.
Well, this man
Constantine, he wrote the first uh laws
contrary to the law of God. And anybody
who wasn't willing in the early times of
Christianity to obey was persecuted. But
they overcame him by the blood of the
lamb and by the sword of their
testimony, which was the word of God.
And they loved not their lives unto the
death. Revelation 12:11. So these
persecuted ones suffered under this
tremendous attack of the dragon. So
early Christianity was based totally and
completely on God's word and they
believed that they were justified freely
by his grace through the redemption that
is in Christ Jesus. Romans 3:24. So the
divine system is totally the opposite.
It's the authority of God. It's the word
of God, the love of God, the law of God,
the teachings of God. Now, what does
Robert Schuler say about that? He says,
"No, we've got it all wrong. We must get
away from this idea that religion is
God-based. It should be manbbased." So,
aren't we back in the system of Babylon?
Yes or no? He's teaching a Babylonian
religion. So, he's part of Babylon. And
the woman was arrayed in purple and
scarlet color, decked with gold,
precious stones, pearls, having a golden
cup in her hand, full of abominations,
and the filthiness of a fornication. We
did a whole lecture on that. I'm not
going to repeat that. But this is what
the system is all about. Revelation
17:12, "Come hither, I will show unto
thee the judgment of this great
apostate system that sits upon many
waters with whom the kings of the
earth." Unfortunately, we saw that when
we did the United Nations lecture and
the new world order have committed
fornication and the inhabitants of the
earth have been made made drunk with the
wine of a fornication and the whole
world believes all these strange
doctrines which are not even biblical.
Christianity became popular
and well it became a majority religion.
They are as much heathen as they were
before. For error and corruption now
came in upon the church like a flood.
Where is history? Church history. Page
54. This is just a fact. Revelation
predicted that thousands would be
deceived as the false teachings of
ancient Babylon entered the church. And
why?
Ephesians 6:12. For we wrestle not
against flesh and blood, but against
principalities and powers and rulers of
darkness of this world, against
spiritual wickedness in high places. We
worship God. And if we dare to worship
God, we have the eye of the serpent upon
us. And well, many people capitulate and
rather
follow him. But if you stay with Christ,
then this is your battle. You will
wrestle against these. And there will
never come a time until you go to your
grave that you will not face this ad
adversary. So the king of Babylon's word
issued from his throne under the
authority of the son god and that was
law. Whatever he said was law. But the
bible says and he is the head of the
body the church. Jesus is the head who
is the beginning the firstborn from the
dead that in all things he might have
the preeeminence. So two systems today.
We have a papacy that says all power
under my feet. And we have Christianity,
true Christianity, which says all power
under Jesus's feet. And the two never
shall meet except in opposition.
There will come a clash. History repeats
itself. Thou shalt not make unto thee a
graven image. Thou shalt not bow down
thyself to them, nor serve them. Exodus
24:5. So they had literal ones. Today we
have perhaps more spiritual graven
images, but they're there. Notice what
Ezekiel said of his time. Ezekiel 8:16.
At the door of the temple of the Lord,
between the porch and the altar were
about five and 20 men with their backs
towards the temple of the Lord and their
faces towards the east and they
worshiped the sun towards the east.
There you have sun worship. So their
backs were towards the temple and God
had designed the temples in such a way
that they faced in the opposite
direction of pagan worship systems.
That's interesting. We'll see why in a
moment. And yet they turned their backs
on the temple and faced east.
Interesting. So their backs were there
and the sun was a foremost god with
heathenom. This is an interesting quote.
The son has worshipeth as this hour in
Persia and other lands. There is in
truth something royal kingly about the
sun making it a fit emblem of Jesus the
son of justice. Hence the church in
these countries would seem to have said
keep that old pagan name. It shall
remain consecrated, sanctified, and thus
the pagan Sunday
dedicated to Bala became the Christian
Sunday sacred to Jesus. The Catholic
world, March 1894, page 809.
Sunday being the day on which the
Gentiles solemnly adored that planet,
the sun. The Christians thought it fit
to keep the same day and the same name
of it that they might not appear
causelessly peevish and by that means
hinder the conversion of the Gentiles.
So this is what Roman Catholicism did.
They just took it up. And the old sun
worship is alive and living today. In
Egypt, the sun was represented by a huge
red dot. We'll talk about the red dot at
a later stage. And you'll be surprised
where it pitches up in the world today.
And of course the birth of the sun god.
Here we have the goddess uh Nut giving
birth to the son temple of Hattorur.
There she consumes the son and then she
gives birth to him and he is born. You
have the same in the uh Egyptian system
over there. The son being born then she
gives birth and the son god is born.
Same in the Aztec religion in Mexico,
the sun god being born by the woman.
Here you have the throne of Sri Lankan
kings. You have the sun over there as
part of the worship system. The throne
of pharaohs had the sun on it and the
Roman throne had the solar disc on it.
So they were all pagan sun worship
systems. If you go into Egyptology, you
will find the red discs in the horns and
you have the lions support the sun disk
and the horizon. That was part of
Egyptian religion. So if we look at our
days, Monday was the moon's day with the
assimilation of the Anglo-Saxon and
Scandav Scandinavian pagan gods. T was
uh one of the oldest gods of the north
mythology identified with Mars. And then
we have tak Tuesday.
Wednesday was from voden or odin to
thunder god in Germany. In German it's
donastak. The word donna means thunder
of the early Germanic people became
synonymous with Thursday. Then we had
equated it with Roman Jupiter. Friday is
named after defrig the wife of Odin the
mother of another pagan god. Balder.
There you have all of those. the day of
Saturn or Sat Day followed by Sunday,
the day of rest and recreation as it is
observed today, the sun and myth. That's
a UNESCO publication. So they're telling
us today our whole system, our whole
culture is based on pagan sun worship.
If you look at Clovian, he had the sun
right there.
And the sun symbols that the papacy uses
today and the masonic symbols go beyond
anything that can be mentioned. There's
a whole lecture in another series which
is called the wine of Babylon. If you
want to see all the symbolism in
Catholicism that deals with with sun
worship. Isis horosep the emblem of the
Jesuit order means Isis Horus seep the
Egyptian trinity. And you can pick up
all of these symbols in the basilas.
Very fascinating. The crosses here, the
symbols of the birds, the symbols of the
the yantras of all the pagan sun worship
deities. And uh this one is very
interesting over here. This is the sun
god Helios in the pagan tomb discovered
in 1574 beneath St. Peter's Basilica.
You see the Vatican
is built on a pagan p temple site. In
fact, every cathedral in the world is
built on a pagan temple site where
possible. And there will be certain
criteria that have to be met. They're
also built where possible facing east,
which is of course the opposite of what
the Bible has to say on this issue. If
you go into Vatican Square, you have the
largest solar wheel in the world. The
wheel within the wheel emulating the
throne of God, which is a wheel within a
wheel. This is an eight-spoke wheel.
It's called the solar wheel. And it is
basically saying this is the throne of
God. Here's the symbol of Shamash. And
you'll see it's two crosses, one with a
spike and one with a wavy line. The wavy
represents the female and the spike
represents the male. is the symbol of
Shamash and uh Shamash was of course the
deity which is the equivalent of Pan.
Pan was the god of the forest. Diana was
his consort. She was the goddess of the
forest. So if you want to look at your
forestry department, go and look at its
emblem, your own one. I saw it today at
your forestry station. It's the symbol
of Shamash. Very interesting. And here's
another symbol up there, a cylinder seal
of Persian with you have the symbol of
Zoroastaster up there. And here you will
find it in Bombay being used today.
You'll find it with Zorastian priesthood
which is alive and alive today. This is
the system of worship. The flame is a
symbol of the sun in Bombay. Here are
the priests working with a flame.
Symbols of Shamash. Symbols of sun
worship you'll find in Buddhism. You'll
find them in Islam. You'll find them in
the yin-yang system. The knowledge of
good and evil, male, female, the ank,
you'll find it all over the place.
Vishnu, Zorasta, quitzel, cottle. Uh
here you have the mitzm, you'll find it
on the Roman Catholic cathedrals on the
floors everywhere. This is pagan sun
worship at its best. You'll find the
chanuk with its one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine burning
lamps. I was amazed when I was in Israel
and I saw the big banners of the manora
with nine candles and I thought, what's
happened to them? This is blatant
paganism
being flashed on their walls all over
Israel. The trickolon if you go to
Hinduism the alf the number one the
first one has the sun symbols on it. Uh
ha, seat on elephant decorated with
solar motifs. Elephants in Hinduism. Alf
means the first one. The one one is a
symbol of Lucifer. If you went into the
ancient religion, Horus was depicted as
an as a as a bird of prey. If you go
into the Indian religions of the world,
that is also how they depict their
deity. If you go to the Indian uh witch
doctors, the shamans, you'll see the
solar sun worship systems on their back.
This is the system of worship today.
Nothing has changed. If you go to the
Asante Empire, they have Anubis over
there. They have the keys. That's same
as the papacy. They have all the solar
systems of sun and moon and stars and
all the traditional dresses that you
find for example in uh the east block
countries. Those are all symbols of sun
worship. So here is a charismatic group
going to worship in Israel. And what are
these symbols around their necks? What
has this got to do with Christianity?
This is pagan sun worship. Nothing else.
Here you have literal sun worship today.
This is in England. This is Stonehedge.
And here you have the Druids. Notice how
the Druids are dressed very much like
nuns. Well, basically there's no
difference except that most nuns don't
even know that they have drudish
worship. And it's very, very sad.
European sun worship rituals, jumping
through the fire, something which God
forbade. Druid ceremonies at Stonehenge,
for example. Now, Stonehenge is a very
interesting place. You see at stone edge
you have the circle
of stones. Now originally there was a
passage leading up to the circle and
this passage consisted of giant stones.
Well later on what they did is they
covered up the giant stones and put a
roof on it. And that's the basic
structure of a cathedral. And behind
ancient cathedrals you'll have the
circular garden. And if you go into the
center of the garden, you will find a
stone in the middle which is the dot
within the center which is the pagan
system of you know well fertility and
all those good things. And if you look
in those circle gardens you will find
pans you'll find Diana you'll find the
consorts all nicely hidden in the
gardens. I've been in a number of them
in England and in Europe and it's always
quite fun to take aerial photographs to
see where they still have the original
circular structures. So today when you
go into cathedral you have this long
passage and you have the circle at least
as a window which is known as the solar
window and the giant pillars which
separated the side chambers represent
the same as the stones of Stonehenge.
It's also interesting that the great
places of sun worship today lie on what
is called lay lines. So if you took a
line and you stretched it from
Stonehenge, it would go through Paris,
through Rome, through the pyramids to
Mecca in one straight line. The
principal places of sun worship.
Fascinating story. Of course, in the
cathedrals, you'll find the gargoyles
and all these interesting things. Solar
symbols and feasts in France summer
solstice jumping of the fire on the
feast of St. John 19th century engraving
jumping through the fire things that
they do today at the feast of St. John
they still today light the fire
symbolizing the victory of the sun god
today it's called the festival of St.
Jean.
And if you go into the Eastern
religions, you'll find every single one
of their little movements, their hand
movements, their dances are all sun
rituals. And uh you'll notice that this
hand movement over here where he stands
like this. This is an ancient pagan
sis symbol and the papacy uses it as a
blessing. If you go through Masonic
rituals, you'll find that u certain
masonic organizations use this as well.
Uh know anyone who has to make an oath
this way?
Boy Scouts for example make an oath this
way. Pagan systems of sun worship used
by the papacy and all of these.
So the dragon persecuted the woman which
bought brought forth the man child
and to the woman were given two wings of
a great eagle that she might fly into
the wilderness. Can you see how Satan
adopts all the symbols that God has for
himself? He co he copies everything.
basically is just nothing but a copycat
that she might fly into the wilderness
into a place where she is nourished for
a time, times, and half a time from the
face of the serpents. 538 to 1798.
The Valdenzas, the Albigenzers, the
Hugenos, they escaped from her wroth as
many as could. The others were
relentlessly slaughtered. The Valdenzas
in the Valdenzian Valley, faithful men
and women of God, kept the lamp of truth
burning. But their crowning offense was
their love and reverence for scripture
and their burning zeal to make converts.
But many of them had the whole of the
New Testament by heart. Surely, if ever
there was a God-fearing people, it was
these unfortunates under the ban of
church and state. The sign of ador
discerning worthy of death was that they
followed Christ and sought to obey the
commandments of God. It's an interesting
point. This was contrary to the law of
God. So the Valdenzas
were persecuted and this comes from the
history of the Inquisition of the Middle
Ages. This is historic work. Great
numbers were driven from their
habitations with their wives and
children stripped and naked. Many of
them inhumanely massacred. They took the
little children. They bashed their heads
against the rock. Typical. Read the
Jesuit oath. And you will see what they
did to them. They herded them into caves
and made fires and roasted them alive.
They were really mean mean to them. And
many of them were slaughtered and
captive. And the Inquisition can really
talk about all that were heres heretics
deciding for oneself what one shall
believe and practice. Thank God I don't
serve a God like that. Therefore, by
this present apostolic writing, we give
you a strict command that by by whatever
means you can, you destroy all these
heresies and destroy them from your
dascese, all who are polluted by them,
you shall exercise the ecclesiastical
power against them, and all who have
made themselves suspected by associating
with them. They may not appeal against
your judgments, and if necessary, you
may cause the princes and the people to
suppress them with a sword. That's what
happened. That's history. So the dragon
persecuted the woman and Pope Leo had
this medallion printed or pressed where
he has the woman with a cup in her hand
fides on the back. And today there are
just some remnants in the Valdenzian
valleys of how these people lived and
what they did in high up out of reach
places. And the church proudly showed
Lyola, the Jesuit founder, slaughtering
the opposition. The two that are at the
base of his sword are Luther and Calvin.
They harried them out of the land. Johan
Hus, he was one of the first heralds.
First, he was not allowed to say the
mass and he was only allowed to speak,
which was a blessing. And from this very
pulpit, all he could do was preach the
word of God. Marvelous. So all the
liturgy fell away and the word of God
was made perfect. And he called the
papacy Babylon, the king of Babylon.
This was his original church. There was
his pew and up against the wall he had
the poster of the pope riding on a great
horse. And then he had another poster of
Jesus on a donkey and he says, "Who is
mightier,
the servant or the master?" Interesting
questions. Well, he died at the stake
for his troubles and uh was betrayed.
And here they hung up the bodies of
those that refuted them. These are the
Hugeno monuments. We've discussed those.
So the Martin Luther and the Malangs,
this one the fiery one, this one the
gentle one. Sometimes you need people
like Peter. Sometimes you need people
like John Martin Luther, John Wliffe,
John Ox Tindle, Calvin. These were the
great preachers.
And the serpent cast out his mouth of
water as a flood after the woman. So
what did he use? He used the nations of
the world to persecute. He used
particularly France. France will have a
tremendous account to give one day.
Verse 15 said, "And he said, Revelation
17:15 declares, "And he says unto me,
the waters which thou sourest where the
horse sitter are peoples, multitudes,
nations, tongues." We don't have to
guess.
So the nations were sent to persecute
God's people. But the earth where there
was no water opened up its place. So
they fled. They came to the United
States. They are living right here in
this country today. The offspring of
these brave people. They went to Africa.
They started a new life. And their
symbol represents freedom but
unfortunately with a bite in it. It's
masonic.
And the dragon was wroth with the woman,
and he went to make war with a remnant
of her seed. Now,
this woman fled into the wilderness for
1,260
days. That le brings us up to the date
1798.
And she flees into the solitary places.
And the new world is populated. And
Protestantism
takes hold in the new world.
And out of this Protestantism, a new
remnant arises. And the dragon was wroth
with the woman, with the church. And
then he went to make war with the
remnant of her seed. Now, who are they?
Well, here's an attribute
which keep the commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus Christ.
There's the clue. And we will have to
find out from the Bible who this is. I'd
like to know who is this remnant that
makes the dragon angry, that keeps the
commandments of God, and has the
testimony of Jesus Christ. And what does
that mean?
Well, Daniel says, "And at that time
shall Michael stand up, the great prince
which stands for the children of thy
people, and there shall be a time of
trouble, such as never was since there
was a nation, even at that same time."
And at that time, thy people shall be
delivered, everyone that shall be found
written in the book. Wow. We are living
in the very end of time. The woman of
the wilderness is over. The dragon is
now wroth with the remnant of her seed,
they that keep the commandments of God
and hold to the testimony of Jesus.
But Michael will stand up before he can
destroy them.
And I will destroy thee, oh covering
cherub. Therefore will I bring forth a
fire in the midst of thee, and I shall
devour thee, and I will bring thee to
ashes upon the earth. Ezekiel 28:16 and
18. This battle between these two
gigantic forces, Michael and his angels
and his church, the woman, and Satan and
his angels and his church, the of
Babylon. Those two are going to come
into a final clash.
And it would be interesting to know
whether both sides can identify the
other. That would be exciting. What if
the one side literally said that's them?
We'll see. Blessed are they that do his
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life and may enter
in through the gates into the city.
Revelation 22:14. So, it's really worth
it
to keep the commandments of God, not to
earn your place in heaven, but because
you choose to obey God rather than man.
That's the crux of the matter. It's a
question of obedience out of love, not
obedience to gain something.
To gain something. The Bible says godly
sorrow leads to repentance.
But there is a sorrow which does not
lead to repentance.
What's the difference between those two?
The sorrow that does not lead to
repentance is a sorrow over loss, not
over what you have done.
A sorrow that leads to repentance is a
sorrow that leads to the acknowledgment
that I
am at fault and I have a problem and I
am in need of a savior. And when I have
recognized him, Jesus Christ, and I take
hold of him and am empowered by him to
start cleaning up the act and doing what
is right, it is he that does it, not me.
and it is by his grace that I am saved
and not by my works. So yes, they keep
the commandments but not to earn their
way to heaven but rather because they
admire and honor their savior, their
redeemer. Two systems at war, a dragon
and a woman in white. and the attributes
they keep the commandments of God and
they hold to the testimony of Jesus.
Ephesians 4 verse four and 5 says there
is one body, one spirit just as you were
called to one hope when you were called,
one Lord, one faith, one baptism. Are
there thousands of faith that lead to
heaven or one?
One and only one? And tonight we will
have to make a decision which side we
are going to be on. Either the one or
the other. And of course we will have to
know more details before we can
understand the full wow relevance of
this mighty battle between these two
ideological systems. The one says you
will obey man. The other one says you
will obey God. And those two systems are
going to clash. In tomorrow night's
lectures, we're going to put it on the
table, let the Bible do the talking, and
we're going to go straight to the hub of
the matter. And then we will see in the
subsequent lectures exactly who's making
war on who, what the final outcome will
be, and what the intervention of God is
going to be like. In the Bible, we're
going to do those fantastic chapters.
Revelation chapter 10, Revelation 14, 12
and 13. We've already done. We're going
to do the final chapters, the
restoration of all things. Don't miss it
because this is what
the final answer is. Without it, you
will only know what's bad, but you won't
know what the solution to the problem
is. So, God bless you and keep you as
you ponder these things. And see you
tomorrow.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Woo!
Oh,
come on.
Heat.